hey it's a little cedaw check me out on
the bootleg kev podcast
little ceto's here welcome bootleg head
podcast and we're in the building man
two five three [ __ ] well first of all
congratulations because you've gone
super viral over the last like week or
so um
i want to say like when i first saw your
page you had like 10 000 followers and
uh or something like
you've had a big jump this week right
yeah yeah i've gone up like what like
i think one of like 50 000 instagram
followers in the last like two weeks
something crazy right so crazy you have
this uh fizzler freestyle cipher yeah
that goes crazy
um
was it chris brown that reposted you
yeah yeah a whole lot of people tapped
in off it but chris brown uh yeah he
reposted it like i think a couple days
ago shout out to chris breezy most
definitely is there a dm conversation
there uh
nah no no i mean like i hit him if i was
like yo this is my song i appreciate i'm
like this is my uh this is me rapping i
appreciate it because you know he ain't
tagged me is it seen huh huh the dm did
he see it no
not yet i think it's way too many
messages for the difference
so listen you're a 16 year old kid yep
um
where are you from i'm from i was born
like people get a twist i was born in
port angeles but like i was born and
then i was transported immediately to
pee wallop so like i was like raised in
puyallup washington the state of
washington yeah
so
a lot of people say like because
obviously this is a bay area platform
yeah but a lot of people always say like
oregon and uh washington are kind of
like extensions of the bay
in terms of just like culture some of
the tastes that people like i could see
it if they're talking about like music
culture right because like because like
washington doesn't really have its own
sound
and like there's been people like
hundreds of thousands of people trying
to perfect like trying to make a
washington sound but like you can't like
when you think of washington what do you
think of like macklemore or lilmozy
travis thompson travis thompson yeah
travis thompson
uh
but but nobody's at all three of those
names nobody sounds the same
yeah there's like not a sound yeah
they're all like travis thompson's on
the more like poppy like upbeat [ __ ]
moses on more like the more smooth
vibing stuff and uh mclemore's just
found the like
like storytelling stuff all three of
them have tapped in with me in the last
like week or two oh wow yeah macklemore
tapped in yeah mclemore uh he
i got my cypher verse got posted on a
washington page called dub ctv
and he follows it because he's from
seattle so he like follows the
washington news page
and uh
he followed me and like i was like like
damn like i show my mom like because my
whole family's just like macklemore's a
legend and he's he's a great dude and
everybody can listen to him you know
it's like yo grandma could listen
everybody can you see macklemore yeah
and i told my whole family i was i was
going nuts i was flipping out and then i
hit and then he hit me up he was like
keep going bro you're snapping i was
like i really appreciate it and then uh
but yeah he's been showing love on a lot
of my posts you know he's been he
follows me you know he's been
he's been showing a lot of love lately
yeah he's a good dude and uh i feel like
he really goes hard for that area oh
yeah yeah he he's i think he's like
i don't know if he's like
an uh a part owner of the i think it's
the soccer team right this is the
yeah i think he's like a part owner of
that and i know he's him and marshawn
lynch you know marshawn lynch i mean
obviously yeah they both uh like co-own
the hockey team the uh [ __ ] they got
that they got that fly jersey i forgot
the name they got a [ __ ] ill jersey
the jersey's hard i'm not gonna lie the
jersey is hard it's the um
this uh
it's like the the kraken seattle oh
seattle cracking yeah yeah is that the
name seattle cracker yeah it's the crap
that's probably yeah look at me knowing
more about your [ __ ] team than you
[ __ ]
anyway so you're about an hour outside
of seattle
uh yeah like an hour 45 minutes um so
you're obviously a kid man are you like
it's summertime
um
what are you are you in school still are
you like what's what's what's going on
like with your life as a kid trying to
make it in the rap game man uh
i don't go to school no more like yeah
it's summertime but i don't go to like
public school no more because like
so like i got a girl like my girlfriend
goes to my school and like whenever like
we would be walking in the hallways
together like people would be hollering
like like like and whenever we would go
to football games like that would say
like weird [ __ ] like oh make out do this
do this do that like just making my girl
feel mad uncomfortable because my girl's
not like really uh she's not used to all
this [ __ ] going on so i just i was like
you know i don't want to be a
distraction for what you got going on so
i'm just gonna i'm gonna take a step
back and also because like there was a
lot of [ __ ] going around in school
so it was like
people
you know in the rap game people want to
like try to go viral by like testing
somebody so it's people in school like
trying to like do trying to catch a
clout moment yeah yeah yeah and uh like
i would be getting in fights all the
time so like because because people want
to go viral want to want to do this do
that and they think just like just
because i'd be on tick tock and i'm like
up like did like the [ __ ] like
that it's all going to be cool and sweet
that's not that's not what it is so
you're in school
buzzing obviously this cypher moment has
kind of puts you on a different level
but in terms of like
you're known as a rapper at school yeah
you're in a relationship at school yeah
and because you're getting so much
attention
it's kind of making your school
experience a little shitty especially
for your girl you're saying yeah i mean
i could sit on here and lie all day and
act like i'm a great student because
i've never really been a great student
and that and that's not like i can't
blame nobody but myself i never really
just i never really saw the value in
school and i may sound ignorant saying
that but it's just putting them bars
together man yeah it's just like i feel
like there's always something like i
feel like there's something like i feel
like i could be taught more valuable
things outside of this
are you gonna finish and get a i'm gonna
get a g i'm gonna get a general
education but if you're gonna get the
ged yeah if i don't get a ged i'm gonna
do online and get a diploma because like
i'm still going to get a backup plan
because i'm fully accepted with the fact
that i could i could fall off tomorrow
like yeah this rap [ __ ] is finicky man
yeah and and longevity is a really
really difficult thing in it so you know
i just
it's like
i i understand that
you know i'm on this show today
everyone could forget about me tomorrow
so i'm always accepting and
understanding with the fact that like i
could fall off any day like we've seen
it like like everybody who's like
followed the music industry and like
paid the slightest bit of attention
right we know who's falling off and
who's stayed relevant over the last
couple of years you feel me yeah i think
um
you know if there's anything that's like
a testament to like
the soundcloud era of music yep all
those guys are pretty much down bad
right now because the music has to cut
through exactly so like as long as
you're focused on making timeless [ __ ]
bro and making sure your [ __ ] is like
not antic based does that make sense
yeah yeah that's why like her instance
like little uzi that's why he doesn't
follow like he hasn't fell off that's
why like little baby uh young boy it's
because like they can all like they go
they all know how to make a hit like
they all know what it takes to make a
hit
and
like i admire it i admire people that
got longevity like people could talk all
the [ __ ] about them they want but
soldier boy he's got longevity like a
[ __ ] he's the soldier boy's just
like he's kind of like a
less famous version of snoop dogg like
soulja boy will always be paid
because of who he is like there's
exactly there's a my homie manager
soldier boy yeah um shout out my guy
theo but there's always like soulja
boy's always gonna have a bag he's got
hits he's like a character in the
culture you know what i'm saying he's
starting like a console brand in a shop
exactly so it's like no matter what like
soulja boy's got a bag to get it might
be in japan it might be a [ __ ] bar
mitzvah but he's getting a bag you know
either way but uh so
how long have you been making music
uh
i was in
i was ending fifth grade i didn't have a
phone no i did have a phone i stole i i
forgot i had a phone and i downloaded
garageband and then i started [ __ ]
like i had some [ __ ] written and then
uh
i had some [ __ ] written then i spit it
on garageband then i found the beat
after and then i posted it
and then people at my school started
hearing about it sixth grade like the
end of fifth grade okay
and people was like just making like gas
and like making fun doing this doing
this you know and it was expected like i
i go back and i listen to some of my
music like all of my music that [ __ ] is
weak there's no exception to it but like
i took it personal because i always felt
like okay you don't like it you're going
to like it soon like if you and even if
you don't like it you're going to be
forced to pay attention because if i'm
all over your screen you don't got no
choice but to pay attention because if
you see me here oh oh look i remember
him from fifth grade whoopty whoop like
if you see me
uh how do i how do i work this how do i
work this it's like
if you don't [ __ ] with me
okay
but
you're not gonna get rid of me like i'm
going to be around you know and i told
everybody like that laughed at me i was
like all right [ __ ] you i'ma go i'm
going to do the and i started this [ __ ]
all on my own like
i had some people i used to [ __ ] with
that i like i uh
like i would record at their house or
whatever but like there's nobody that
like i started like making music with
that i [ __ ] with now because
you know
enviousness and jealousy because like
when like everything started popping
like in like may of last year when i
posted it i was on tick tock and i
posted my song mafia and it went crazy
and i like
some [ __ ] like this ain't never happened
before so
i was like i was excited
and i was like telling all my homies
about who i started the music [ __ ]
whether i was like hey bro my like my
tick tock hit like a hundred thousand
views like i got like 10 000 followers
like and they were happy for you was the
other way around huh yeah it was just
that they like
after the first time it was like okay i
see you blah blah blah blah and then
after a while there was like bruh stop
flexing on and stop bragging i said i'm
like bro y'all see what i had to come
from to get here right because i'm a
white rapper it's not like you you gotta
like it's it's hard to like
uh you're not just a white rapper you're
a 16 year old white rapper yeah but but
at this time i was a fifth
fourteen-year-old like [ __ ] crazy
yeah i was just did you look more like
justin bieber then then you do now
i could pull up pictures for you you got
like 10 years ago like the 2011
thing popping i like it man you know i
get that a lot but like i could pull up
pictures from when i was seven eight
years of course i'm talking about baby
era bieber yeah i've always kept this
haircut
it's just because like i don't like i
don't care like people tell me like oh
get this hair could get the light you
look like like it like it looks fine on
me like
like it looks fine on me my girl thinks
i look good my mom thinks i look good
hey by the way you you so did
cause you're young how long have you
been with your girlfriend uh 10 months
10 months well coming up on 10 months
would you say that you left school
primarily because of her or because of
everything i
mean
primarily because of her just because i
care about her and i know that she like
takes her education seriously like my
girl had a 4.0 gpa like she has straight
likes my girls like are really like
really good at school not a white girl
black girl okay good for you yeah and uh
white women are terrible
trust me i've lived for you
yeah but uh
my wife is mexican yeah but uh
so
it like like like
people can say you're too young to fall
in love this that you're in love
i'm in love and i'm gonna admit it you
know i love my girlfriend you know she's
she's been solid with me you know she
she's never did me wrong she's never
done she's like she stayed stayed solid
through any rough patch we've got we've
went through and we got through it
because she she like and she believes in
me like right now she she's sad as hell
that i'm like out of town and like and
lately we haven't been able to see each
other as much like it's gonna be a lot
more of that yeah i know it and she's
and she really like seems like she's
ready for and she and she understands
hey we gotta stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our family our
good folks at odd socks you see me look
these are odd socks basics on my skinny
white [ __ ] legs
i love odd socks go to
oddssocksofficial.com
you're going to get 20 off at checkout
if you use the promo code bootleg kev
that's one word bootleg kev now they got
odd socks which are great my favorites
are the basics they also you know you
got the license one these are the
twizzlers these are baywatch socks but
then you got the basics now these are
what these are
just the plain boys man
they're so comfy all right i always got
the white basics the black basics on and
i always got odd socks underwear on too
they got the draws all right so what are
you doing go to oddssoxofficial.com
use the promo code
bootleg cav save 20 off check out these
[ __ ] draws kool-aid
underwear ladies and gentlemen what are
we doing
odd socks official.com bootleg kev is
the promo code save 20 off right now
let's get back to the interview let me
say this let me give you some game here
you're 16.
i i would say this i might venture to
say
that if i see you again in 12 months
there's gonna be a lot of strange women
around you that aren't your girlfriend
is she prepared for the amount of
[ __ ] that's about to come your way and
by [ __ ] i mean over 18 vagina
have you guys had the talk we we've
talked about it like she gets it like
because there's gonna be women trying to
statutory rape the [ __ ] out of you
shortly try yeah like like right like
there's a lot of like like grown ass
women dming me like all the time like
talking about oh i want to do this i
want to give you this i want to give you
that you trying to get a sugar mama
popping i don't know
like in like the first month of me and
her dating like i told her about it and
this is like woman was up she offered me
five thousand you know all i had to do
was like face time with her like once a
week for a month
and she's a child and then she said she
was
hey you said no no
i took the five thousand dollars and i
blocked her and i gave my girl 2 500.
hey you're a real one what my girl was
like okay if you're gonna be flirting
for these couple little whatever to get
this money just do it but i'm getting
half of the money i was like that's all
good with me what'd this whole [ __ ]
look like
was she like a white lady like a teacher
or something no she was mexican she uh
mexican women aged gracefully
was she overweight underweight
next question i i don't i don't wanna i
don't wanna i'm not no disrespectful she
was she was she was a
she was a she was a rich rich [ __ ] for
sure she's just [ __ ] off five okay
yeah if that's the way you want to put
it then yeah she's just [ __ ] off five
grand on a child yeah but the mvc game
but also
for sure
child molester
for show that's [ __ ] for sure imagine
being a 44 year old lady dm and a 15
year old kid offering him money if that
was the other way around
do you know how [ __ ] that is exactly
like hey like you notice how in like any
of these young rappers that are dudes
that like bro you were being groomed bro
like okay let's say like why being not
me your friends like when he was coming
up and he and like all these like old
women were talking he was like i got old
he was [ __ ] old exactly yeah exactly
but like when bad babies in her songs
talking about i got grown men doing this
doing that it don't sound too good does
it sounds it's yeah exactly it's cringy
exactly but it's crazy but me it's like
it's it's weird either way so you got
groomed
as a child by an old lady on the
internet that's [ __ ] crazy to a
certain extent no i mean you you know
she gave you money i mean yeah she she
gave me five thousand dollars how was
like was it like cash up was it like a
envelope of money it was a wire
she
so i understand it because i'm not 18 so
my cash like cash that be tweaking so i
had him cash up one of my homies and
then he went to the bank got uh got the
money out and then me and my girl split
it she also could have been pulling some
edd [ __ ] yeah man probably maybe there
was some sort of fraud angle going on
there thanks could be
social
uh i gave it to her you gave her your
social i'm playing i'm about to say
you're [ __ ]
she ran it up you better check your
credit i'm not i don't even have credit
you better start hey man listen you're
16.
start saving that money
you could get a secured credit card
right now with 200 from a bank
so by the time you turn 18
you have credit booming
so you're 16 you go to the bank you say
i want to secure a credit card that
means you give them like 200 500 and
then they give you a credit card based
on the money you gave them yeah and then
you use that to buy gas groceries pay it
off every month to zero by the time
you're 18 you have like a [ __ ] 750
bra
don't get credit cards though get a
secured credit card to build your credit
and do you have a car yet
no no [ __ ] a car you don't need a car
not over everywhere yeah uber everywhere
bro you don't need a [ __ ] you want to
know something
you want to know how much i spent on
ubers in the last year how much you got
the you got the grand total
hold on
because i don't got a car anything like
that that money that [ __ ] gave me went
to uber i'm off on the two percent but
uh
facetiming with your girl a [ __ ] day
852.38 that's not terrible
that's actually that's actually pretty
uh
that's actually amazing with gas prices
right now i mean it's like a [ __ ] car
note for like a cord
he said for the year you want to know
how much i thought you were going to say
8 000.
[ __ ] see there's that [ __ ]
washington state ubers i don't live in
washington state where you stay at
jackson mississippi what no taxes there
well you that's not your problem i don't
know why do you live in jackson
mississippi it's a really racist place
no not jackson burning mississippi you
ever see a movie i mean mississippi like
there's like some parts but like jackson
isn't
so why there
uh because like when i moved it was
because i was like 14 when we moved
and
like i was 14. i got to go wherever your
girlfriend's in mississippi yeah okay so
your parents moved there yeah and then
me and her met on the school bus nice
kind of like you ever see
i mean have you ever seen forrest gump
yeah where you met jenny yeah on the bus
similar huh yeah did she kill herself
she overdosed
or no no she didn't she got cancer at
the end right she almost overdosed
though oh our oh yeah oh [ __ ] yes i
remember she was standing above the uh
above the building top and forrest gump
say did he save her did she just talk to
her shoot her shoe she was like super
hot she talked herself down or that's
why i used to love that movie great
movie great movie yeah
bubba gump was a cool dude sweet guy do
you ever get a bubba gum shrimp the
restaurant i've actually heard about it
and i want to try it not great it's not
great no terrible i mean it's not
terrible it's also not great treacherous
it's kind of one of those shitty places
near like every theme park
where you're like oh look they got a
bubba gump and they got a [ __ ] voodoo
donuts and they got a [ __ ] i don't
know insert
what's that [ __ ] margaritaville
it's like the same seven places near you
you could be in florida you could be in
la you could be [ __ ] in houston they
got the same [ __ ] restaurants near
every university studios but what about
his name uh don't they got bubble gum
shrimp in uh miami yeah
i think
they got it in miami i know i saw it in
miami and like i was like oh my god
that's cool like that's a real thing but
like i couldn't i couldn't imagine that
it would have been good i mean it's not
terrible i mean i've got apples
applebee's is just microwave food listen
for a 16 year old though great date
place two for 20.
babe let's go to applebee's afterwards
i'll take you to see minions i mean i
i'm making a have you taken your abc
minions i haven't i just took her to see
uh jurassic park how was it it was it
was i fell asleep halfway through it
like i was just tired like that day like
i had six dude like i had like six hours
i was spent six hours in the studio
and like like after she was like hey you
want to go to the movies she i know she
was telling me she was having a rough
day so i was like let's go so then i got
a lift picked her up took to the movies
like and that's really like all there is
to do out there in mississippi it's like
you either go to the movies you go to
the bowling alley or you chill in the
walmart parking lot there's nothing to
do out there there's no theme parks
there's no there's like the state fairs
like once twice a year and it's always
getting shot up like there's there's not
there's casinos but you can't go there
right
are there casinos in mississippi there's
casinos and clan rallies i mean
wow
i mean i don't like i i'd imagine there
is casino
oh yeah i know there's casinos in biloxi
but luxie is where they are yeah yeah
yeah you're from like it's like just
like the shore that's where uh they got
the that's where young blue lives
yeah he lives in biloxi
uh he said this on the internet on my
podcast so it's not like i married him
out you know oh [ __ ] okay no blue spot
by the way not young blue anymore just
blue
uh so you hang out in the
walmart parking lot no i don't but like
that's like there's nothing to do
there's nothing to do with this okay you
ever go into walmart and hop on the
handicapped scooter all the time it's
[ __ ] great time i'm still 16.
it's a good time yeah i still do it
you should do it yeah why not sometimes
i'll just like yo i'll go with my
grown-up i have a [ __ ] 16 year old
kid jesus christ
[ __ ] my life huh
but i'll just be like yo son i'm gonna
hack my candy cap and parachute
and i'll just like i'll just like
screech from like down the aisle like
like for someone for someone who looks
like me i think that can test me for you
no offense yeah but i don't think they
could test you
yeah thanks buddy i appreciate it i'm
just playing it's okay he called me
buddy it's okay what's what's the
weirdest thing you've seen hanging out
at walmart because i'm sure walmart in
mississippi has got to be a dark place
man there's a lot of [ __ ] maga hats
floating around a lot of [ __ ] i've
seen someone in an aisle roasting win or
rushing hot dogs that sounds about right
like i swear they have cargo shorts on
no they had
they had like bomber bombers like
sweatpants on like the unit like the
ones that you could rip off yeah those
oh wow they probably got them there they
still sell those there i mean i don't i
was a kid those were popular you know
like oh look i could rip my pants off
yeah but like i don't know that was i i
never saw that as cool like that was
just weird to me like why do you like
want to like
that's weird just in case you gotta
never mind just because you gotta get to
it you know what i'm saying i mean i
guess like babe look
well it's really they're for basketball
so if you're like bass if you're if
you're a basketball player i don't think
they use them anymore they don't use
them anywhere they're ridiculous it's a
ridiculous clothing i used to have and
one do you know what and one is oh yeah
i used to have the and one ripoff i used
to always wear the n1 shorts and one
shorts uh well when you were see if
there's a difference between when i was
wearing an one it was cool when you were
wearing an n1 that [ __ ] wasn't goofy
that [ __ ] was that you weren't broke you
were broke like if you got shacks and
some ambulance on your broke what
see when i was a kid shaq had a reebok
deal yeah things were a little different
yeah and one
there was the vince carter's there was
the it was a wave
now
and one not the wave
yeah like p people talk about like how
cheap shocks are this that step but like
you know how much money he's made like
i've seen the same meme you've seen on
the internet i've seen it
we get our information from the same
place memes online
yeah no shout out to shaq they're
affordable shoes i love shaq i'm i'm a
huge supporter of jack do you want do
you like basketball sports
yeah i'm huge on sports like i always
like how you play i used to play
football um what position linebacker
nice yeah but um like junior high school
uh i played like
i played like
like 11 you through like seventh grade
but then like i became academically
ineligible so then i couldn't play no
more he was [ __ ] up huh yeah because
i was getting distracted by a whole
bunch of [ __ ] what would be a whole
lot of [ __ ] in your world
ah i can't really answer that was it
[ __ ] was it not drugs fighting i
can't really answer that no you can't
really answer that i appreciate you
keeping up that mysterious that you're
gonna keep the mystery going for young
thug free young oh so you was part of
ysl
[Music]
he said free young
me free gunner man long live key man
y'all yeah yo shout out to the ysl man
what's going on hey let me ask you this
man cuz you um
your style
it what what would you say is like your
biggest influence because it's very um
it's very
interesting to see a kid your age look
the way you do rap the way you do i'm
sure you're self aware of that so what
would you attribute like kind of your
rapping style to like influence-wise or
just like why are you rapped that way
bro easy e
easy e i [ __ ] with easy
easy easy
uh
the boy
the boy from the bay shout out to sob
boy blue face
like like i'm saying like who i feel
like i could like ass like i could like
uh synonymous
i would probably tell tell this to blue
face to his face but i think you might
be better than him
i mean there's some point like i feel
like he's he's got some funny [ __ ] he
says for sure yeah he's got like way
better some of his punch lines you just
can't like deny no that's funny he said
he said you was never on a blockbuster
you was at the red box everybody got
dead homies [ __ ] i got dead ops like
you was never on the blockbuster you was
at the red box i understand like so much
like you know what that that's the best
blue face liner and what else do you say
uh that's the best blue face line i've
ever what else he said dove enough in
his bench so i can i can afford not to
focus
what jesus christ
are you gonna yo why don't you do a
record with him why is he's while you're
out here
have you tried to work on that
uh i haven't really i haven't reached
out i just you know if you want me to i
could facetime him
he's a good guy yeah he hangs out with a
bunch of crazy ass [ __ ] though you
might want to stay away from that though
your girl might not like that keep chris
away from me she's a wild one a very
yeah i was in the studio with him a
couple weeks ago him and ddg are working
on their joint album he was there
and the toothless girl was in there
while in the [ __ ] out was she toothless
or she or she dude this had to be the
day before or the like two days before
she got the tooth
because like we we were with her and she
had no tooth and then like i want to say
that next day the meme popped up that
she fixed her smile like [ __ ] you know
she like she she got a tooth pulled it
out for for bro and then she got a new
one with blueface's face painted on the
tooth
do you think your girl would get your
face painted on her tooth
or at least on the nails
you never
like i would i would leave my girl if
she did what what did her parents think
of you huh
uh my
damn my girl parents like her stepdad's
uh ex-military and [ __ ] he don't [ __ ]
around
you don't [ __ ] around he's a very big
dude
what's up with this white boy in my
house like like when i first met him
like and he's like a cool guy like like
like he he uh he's taught me a lot
because he's like he's all big on like
christianity and all this like he's like
jesus christ
yeah and uh are you big on jesus just
side note i'm not i'm not really
religious like i don't say like i'm a
christian i'm an atheist i'm this i just
say like like i like there's like a
higher power that i like obviously like
believing in following like mushrooms
and aliens yeah yeah i guess so so her
dad's trying to like he's pretty much
kind of you know
he's been nice to you essentially they
accept you yeah because i haven't like
like i know how to talk to adults like
i'm not like a disrespectful like i'm
not an ignorant kid like you're smart i
can tell man like i'm not like ignorant
like i'm not just gonna walk up in like
my girl's house pants sagging like
talking about what i was like like
i just you know like do you walk
anywhere with your pants sagging
whenever i don't have a belt yes right
but like or whenever i got a lot of [ __ ]
yeah but like not like by choice it's
not like you're like you know i gotta
hang my ass out nah that's that's goofy
nah nah like but like whenever it's not
nice whenever i have a whole bunch of
[ __ ] in my pocket happens to me all the
time yeah like whenever i have a whole
bunch of stuff in my pockets yeah but
like i don't just purposely pull my
pants down that's good i mean it's
important to have a strong relationship
with your
significant other that that was like one
of the one of my biggest like like not
i'm not gonna say missions but one of my
biggest things about like being with her
is like i want to make sure that all the
people who she
who are her first priority her family
like i'm cool with both of her brothers
right like when both of her brothers had
girlfriends you know like i was cool
with them because i knew i was going to
be around them a lot like in her mom her
stepdad like you know like they like i
like i you know try to like no i don't
try to like i keep her respectful like i
met her grandpa like i like i met her
whole family and you know
like they say they like me you know like
i don't i i don't think i've made a bad
impression you know that's dope yeah
seems to be i mean you're pretty mature
for your age man
yeah i the thing is is i don't see like
this may sound corny a lot of people say
it but like i don't like i don't see my
like eight like me like my age is 16 but
like i feel like i can like i have a
like a mind of an adult when it when it
comes down to it because yeah i joke a
lot like i like i like you know i [ __ ]
around with my people but i feel like
i've got a pretty
reasonable
adult base of common knowledge i mean
i'm not stupid if you grow up in today's
world
you can't help but have that yeah
because everything's in front of you you
can learn everything off this yeah like
all you gotta like if if i don't know
what
like like if i don't know how to spell
something hey siri how do you spell this
and then shoot like by the way just so
everyone's very clear here that bag
right there
it has t-shirts in it this ain't a
cereal box no i just want to make sure
people know i don't have a pound of
drugs next to a 16 year old and before
the interview's over i'm going to empty
that [ __ ] bag so everyone sees it i
thought these were t-shirts just want to
be clear it's just a bag with shirts in
it i thought that was the canadian leaf
i just want to be clear just so we're
clear here that's what bootleg cab
podcast got to stop things real quick
tell you about our good folks at blue
chew listen fellas if you're trying to
get your dick right you trying to stay
harder
everyone wants to be hard
can you stay hard
you know what i mean
if you need some help with your dick is
essentially what i'm trying to say
you need to go to bluetooth.com and get
down with uh something that i feel like
is imperative and having yourself a
lovely evening with a lovely young lady
or mail whatever you're into if you go
to bluetooth.com you will get a
bluetooth it has the same active
ingredient as cialis and his viagra
right but guess what it doesn't have the
awkward doctor visits that's right you
don't got to wait in line at some lobby
to go get you some [ __ ] [ __ ] to get
your dick working and have some awkward
conversation with a nurse and then have
an awkward conversation with a doctor
and then he writes you a prescription
and then you go to the pharmacist and
then it's awkward because you pass them
the prescription and everyone knows
you're picking up dick stuff you know
what i'm saying no blue chew you go to
the website it's all online it gets sent
straight to your house in discrete
packaging in a chewable form
listen your first month free
right now when you go to bluechew.com
and you use the promo code bootleg
that's right you get the first month for
free
bluechew.com promo code
bootleg
thank me later all right go get your
dick together fellas hey let me ask you
this you watch euphoria with your girl
i didn't watch it with my girl but she
put me on did you watch all of it i
watched all of it because i got asked
this right because i got a kid at your
age
how accurate would you say like
because it's obviously sensationalized
not at all it's not sensationalized it's
not accurate so it's not accurate like
to like what's what you what kids your
age are actually really [ __ ] with
like you know because it's some wild
[ __ ] right oh [ __ ] that's my kid i'm
like are you all [ __ ] over here
snorting heroin there's like a few wild
kids out there but like right i don't
like i know people like like that like
like i know some people that have done
like some stupid [ __ ] but like right
there's not people just carrying like
eight balls in their socks to school
like i didn't think so like there's not
like i don't know anybody sniffing pills
like i don't know nobody popping perks
at my age like i don't know anybody
doing enough that's good i don't
associate because like me like i don't
pop no pills i don't i don't do no like
drugs like i just hey shout out to you
man hey stay that way bro yeah because
the drug [ __ ] is for the weenies bruh i
mean
you know it i wouldn't say it's for the
it's because you know what kind of drugs
listen no drug [ __ ] is for
the weenies
listen
weed shrooms that's all that is approved
in the bootleg household if you're
[ __ ]
sniffing pills
sipping lean all that [ __ ] [ __ ] like
like
okay people be smoking 30 this is a good
one no
perk 30s are fake
like like they're all tens but like the
30s like well my aunt wendy has a
prescription so unless you get them from
that i mean unless you get them from
money they're not selling arizona yeah
but they're not selling the real
thirties off the street like half the
shit's finished
she just my my uncle's kind of [ __ ] up
you know
she gets all his prescriptions is it my
aunt's like you know anybody who needs
some pecs yeah but actually i knew i
knew somebody and i and i literally cut
him off for this reason he was like
crushing perks and he was putting them
on tinfoil and smoking them through like
like a mcdonald's straw oh yeah like
once i saw him doing that i was like i
told him i was like hey like i'll give
you 16 year old doing that he was like
17. i was like 15. i was like hey i'll
give you
x amount of money i'll say it i'll give
you ten thousand dollars if you stop
doing this [ __ ] and me that that was a
lot of money i don't i didn't have like
that wasn't a lot of money then i got 10
grand to be giving crackheads huh you
got 10 grand at 15 to be given crack
smokers boy
what are you doing i don't know music
game is good for you huh yeah i guess
you could say that what would you cause
like
obviously man
we've seen so many different situations
with artists that are your age and
things didn't go the way that you know a
lot of people had hoped i feel like
you're kind of being very uh smart
i mean you seem like a smart kid but
like what are the things you're doing to
kind of make sure that like
you know your business is right that
your
career is not a flash in the pan because
it can happen
i try to success surround myself with
winners
like
i got one of the best managers in the
game
like
i've got the best and the best team i've
got the best manager in the game i've
got the best team in the game i've got
the best team around me
i always believe if you hang out with
[ __ ] you're going to turn to [ __ ] right
if you hang out with success you're
going to turn you're going to turn to be
successful that's real i'm you're not
going to catch me hanging you're not
going to catch me
in a bedroom with ten of the homies just
smoking and just just just [ __ ]
around that also like if we're not if
i'm around like yeah like i hang out
with with the guys or whatever but like
if we're not like if we're just not
doing nothing productive i'm leaving
yeah your circle's got to reflect who
you want to be man exactly that's why i
like like i only like i don't really
hang out with people like i hang out
with my girl
and like that's it and like my team
because i know that my team's got the
best interest for me and my team is
they've done a lot for me and and
they've showed me like hey
we can do this for you it's just what
are you willing to do to get here like
like like we've got the ticket it's just
like what are you going to do to get the
ticket right you know and i love my
whole team all of them have showed crazy
amounts of love they're all here right
now shout out dooney shout out marty
shout out to uh shout out uh tim shout
out zoe shout out renz jean
uh migo shout out my whole the firehouse
team the whole the lights global team
shout out my whole team
and you know i just
i just can't i'm excited to see what
like
we're going to put together in the next
music wise um
you're like are you working on a project
like what do you got out like what's you
know i feel i'm i'm sure like now that
people are kind of starting to discover
you you're probably getting a [ __ ]
macklemore followed you you know what i
mean you're getting people who are
paying attention to you that
you might not have ever known was
possible so now that you kind of see the
light at the end of the tunnel like
what's what's next for you man you
trying to
i'm working on a deluxe album right now
like like kind of like an ep that's tape
right now i just dropped my debut album
two five three baby i see like two area
code uh yeah p wild up okay and uh i did
a
i did 2.1 million streams in the first
month wow that's big man and i was like
y'all want to deluxe
i posted on ig story like 13 000 people
voted yes and seven people voted no and
there's a lot of hate and ass people out
there so there's gonna be a lot of
random people just clicking no but a lot
of people want it so that's that's what
i'm working on right now you got to link
with the boy yet huh have you linked
with the boy yet i have it me and bro
have chopped it up a couple times you
know we've been tapping in late tapping
in lately you know where uh i'm gonna be
on his new tape and
and he's gonna be on my tape
and uh
and he bro showed a lot of love like i
remember i rapped on his lab like like
two years ago wow he's dope man and even
then he was telling me he was like he
was rocking with me it was crazy i feel
like when sob had their wave i feel like
i feel like he wasn't getting as much
attention as like
definitely not but i feel like he's the
hardest guy in the group yeah definitely
he was the hardest guy out of the whole
thing and like all his solo [ __ ] has
been crazy yeah like that uh that
bananas that he dropped that with the
scent like like the boy is
no question like one of the top
and i say this and there's going to be
no rebuttals or take backs to this
the boy is one of the biggest
and is a future lesbian of the bay area
great guy most definitely
we went to vallejo
um
things got hairy shout out to the crest
in vallejo
we're supposed to shoot some [ __ ] with
the boy but you know i work with empire
so he's on empire but uh yeah i've been
in his area it's [ __ ] wild yeah like
like i went out to oakland for the uh
now we're gonna talk about that but uh
the boy
you know who else is
yeah i think the boy would be hard for
you to work with you know who's hard out
the bae is little russell
have you heard of him
i've heard the name of russell's i don't
i don't want to be on here acting all
famous acting like i don't know nobody
nobody's i just don't like that yeah i
mean i'm not really too familiar who um
for the deluxe is there anyone else that
you want to get on or as far as feature
wise or anything else i'm
linking up with aztek tonight chuck's a
great guy uh
i feel like you and ruchi would make
some [ __ ] i don't know if you [ __ ] with
ruchi ruchi's hard i [ __ ] with urushi i
[ __ ] with you hey i focused that uh song
he made with uh jeep rico keep killing
mm-hmm you know that song yeah yeah fine
i i [ __ ] with jeep rico i [ __ ] if hakuji
rico and i [ __ ] with you heavy and i
[ __ ] with chike i [ __ ] with uh one take
james hard one take one take j is one of
my biggest influences as well like if
through like the whole like west coast
rap scene yeah yeah i think your style
is like i think like what's dope is like
you're saying super clever [ __ ]
it's very uh
easy to digest what you're saying
and
you're [ __ ] you're a kid man like the
fact that you're rapping as good as you
are at your age is crazy yeah i
appreciate it because most people who
are 16 years old trying to rap
you know no disrespect their [ __ ] is
pretty [ __ ]
low-hanging fruit [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying yeah um
so like but there's been some pretty big
like 16 year old like rap that like
really like because like stop bro look
you got doing a little pump yeah i know
he had some [ __ ] like pump had like
bro i swear to god
i was the oldest little pup fan yeah and
i [ __ ] felt weird loving like boss so
much and choppa choppa came out with uh
oh italy chopper papa that beast i saw i
saw choppa live i saw choppa live and i
wrapped his ass off like i [ __ ] with
choppa that's that's one drink like in
the future choppa definitely choppa and
uh
um like there's been a lot of young
talent coming up like uh namir uh
yeah choppa
uh
who else um i mean court a was about
seventeen florida yeah like but like the
thing is about court a is like yeah he
like at the time he wasn't like the
biggest name in the group but bro bro is
the best rapper in the group that's no
question like and that's no shade to not
mirror uh almighty j or nothing it's
just like with the [ __ ] like uh
uh what's his name cordee was saying
yeah like like you couldn't like like
that kung fu [ __ ] he like
when he did that 1985 freestyle and when
he made that uh what was called uh
scottie pippen yeah yeah yeah that's got
it like bro that's i i was blasting
scottie pippen for like three months
straight like and
and now like corde is making his own
wave and he's like actually like
building a huge like name for himself
yeah and you know like i said i don't i
don't got no no shade against any other
member it's just i just think that core
day is the best rapper like well it's
not even a group anymore so yeah yeah
like no shade to any of them it's just
you know like at the time of [ __ ] the
also one of my big influence like cause
like i like i made a uh thing in my
notes like who are my biggest influences
like nami was on there that's dope yeah
hey man it's good it's important to give
flowers to you know people who who
influenced you yeah and also i'm going
to take a couple seconds because i'm
from washington you know there's not too
much spotlight on washington so i want
to shout out some some of my people
shout out my boy gunna goof
uh great name
yeah my boy gonna goof my boy mike jack
3200 two paid make a million
uh rest in peace tan of money rest in
peace the glory sparks rest in peace to
juice the god my boy louise you so
you're familiar with tacoma
yeah louie is a tacoma legend come like
louis he signed a atlantic uh he he's
he's louie big big tacoma guy cohen's
what about a
60 minutes outside of seattle
oh i think like 30 maybe 20 30. don't
y'all have the same radio stations kind
of
92.5 93.3
yeah also uh
but louie uh ec a lot of bands don't
[ __ ] with me no more but shout out my
guy d stacks were you just shattered him
i'll just
these names are crazy you're saying yeah
yeah but today's names ec got a lot of
bands ec lot of bands d stacks
uh shout out to them man yeah when's the
deluxe dropping
so yeah i know as much as you do there
it is i don't even know the new project
is out right now just drop two five
three baby two five three baby it's out
now all platforms and it's just doing go
run it up uh congrats on all this uh
attention you're getting you're dope
um and uh yo man
just
you know
now's your time to blow up bro so just
know that like uh
a lot of crazy shit's gonna come your
way and you gotta [ __ ] you gotta
learn how to like deal with it still
keep your head on strong bro definitely
and if you [ __ ] you know
it's crazy you have a girlfriend during
this time in
in in life but yeah it's crazy like
she's sticking with me she she's solid
yeah but yeah get your ged man get your
[ __ ] you know definitely yeah you
playing video games yeah what are you
playing uh warzone call of duty uh
warzone 2k madden you play that elden
ring [ __ ] uh-huh elden ring yet oh no i
just thought that [ __ ] it's supposed to
be the game of the year oh [ __ ] i'll be
busting my manager's ass in war zone
every other day
oh not that guy right there oh that guy
that guy is the worst player to play
with on words but you're also a child
but you're also a child you should be
dude every time i try to play any of
these [ __ ] games i put the headphones
on and all i do is hear kids that are 88
years old and i'm just like and they're
[ __ ]
so good
it's frustrating like i wish i could i
feel like it's because their fingers are
faster yeah it's like arthritis hasn't
kicked in like yeah they're gonna have
carpal tunnel bruh for sure there it is
man well look i appreciate you pulling
up definitely
and uh yeah go follow this guy and uh
any anything else you want to plug
before you get out of here uh y'all
gonna stream my new release internet
shooter out on all platforms uh my new
music video and it's an internet shooter
everybody uh
just why internet shooter real quick
it's because in the song i say you just
be typing hella gangster you an internet
shooter so it's like like you type
gangster like you're an internet shooter
right you're like it's like it's there's
a meme on uh
instagram it was like this dude with a
lion mask it was a cat no it was a uh
it was like a like a weak little it was
like a rat with a lion mask and they
were like typing
that's that's basically what it is hey
it's crazy we're sitting here talking
with the 16 year old who's wrapping his
ass off right now trying to hey man
congratulations and uh yeah just stay
keep keep [ __ ] together man
yeah there it is
ceto appreciate you bro no problem